we may have already contaminated Mars
the discovery of water on Mars I think
really does argue strongly for the
possibility of life on Mars not just in
the past but today Mars started out as a
warm and watery planet a lot like Earth
and it's totally possible that life
might have started on Mars and come to
earth there you can't rule that
possibility out and if there's a if
there was water on Mars we have to take
that possibility seriously if there
still is water on Mars we have to
continue to take that seriously in other
words there could still be life hanging
out on the planet we can go to
alternative incredibly nasty places on
earth incredibly dry cold places and we
find bacteria and viruses there they are
alive
these things aren't growing very quickly
but they're there so if life started on
Mars that could be eking out an
existence maybe just under the surface
living off of this water that we're
starting to see pictures of and that's
actually a problem if we want to go to
Mars because if we're going to Mars to
discover life we'd better be sure that
we're not contaminating Mars with all of
our bacteria and viruses because we
could just ruin the place in terms of
understanding the life that's there and
so it's really hard to sterilize a
spaceship and everything on it including
the astronauts so this whole issue of
planetary protection which nASA has a
whole office for is going to get a lot
more serious I think